sometimes we are just thirsty or too hot
but most often our insomnia is
psychological it is the mind's revenge
for all the efforts that we have largely
unbeknownst to us been making not to
have certain thoughts in the day
we are being woken up by a need to think
about something that we have carefully
been ignoring probably thanks to our
work or our social and family
commitments having attempted to get our
attention by more normal means in the
clamor and busyness of the day our deep
minds are now trying to get us to have
an appointment with certain insights and
ideas in the quieter hours of the night
our 3am Awakenings are signs that we
have repeatedly not been doing the sort
of self-reflection we need to do in
order to be at peace we're not being
lazy we're not shunning our
responsibilities out of willfulness
we're simply escaping for very
understandable Reasons from what are
liable to be a range of difficult
thoughts perhaps about work a
relationship or our childhoods
if we're to regain sleep we should begin
to visit with greater tenderness and
Imagination than we allow ourselves in
the day some of the bolted and locked
rooms of our minds
in a spirit of gentle curiosity we might
dare to raise certain sorts of inquiry
what am I truly truly sad about at the
moment
who has hurt me
what needs to change what is the real
grief beneath the surface anxiety
what is my gut telling me I need to know
now
and to do next
these can be uncomfortable questions no
doubt but we can use the night to help
us to face them everyone else is asleep
it matters a little less now that we
think in conventional ways we can be a
bit odd fanciful imaginative and kind we
can go a little mad between 3 and 4 AM
and no one needs to know we can write
things down in a notebook and destroy
the pages in the morning what counts is
that we give ourselves the chance to
understand our shy and pained deep
psyches a little better
they've been crying out for our
attention and we have till now run away
from our duty of care
our mind's ultimate responsibility is
always to our growth and our
self-understanding they want us to sleep
of course they understand as well as any
expert that rest is important but they
have as a priority something even more
important than energetic Limbs and that
is psychological insight they need us to
have felt what needs to be felt to have
been angry where we are in a rage to be
sad where we are grief stricken they are
irrepressibly driven to try to align our
surfaces with our depths they are trying
to send us as it were to the school of
night not to be unkind but so that we
can catch up on some very key lessons
about who we really are that we have
until now been too distracted or
squeamish to attend we will sleep better
once we begin to ask ourselves these
questions on a regular basis